jetzt sind wir in der welt drin und wir
können jetzt zum abspielen sollte das
beibringen oder nein
okay die youtuber sind auf dieser
plattform zu hause hier drehen wir
unsere videos hier interagieren wir mit
unserer community und wir sind
mittlerweile relativ gewohnt daran
einfach mit einer kamera zu reden ohne
dass irgendein im raum ist aber wenn
youtuber ins fernsehen gehen dann
passieren manchmal seltsam seltsam
deswegen weil man als youtuber natürlich
gewohnt ist zu hause in seinem zimmer zu
sitzen seinem gewohnten setting mit
einer kamera zu reden mikrofon vor sich
zu haben aber eben nicht in einem
tv-studio zu sitzen wo ein moderator zu
text ein riesenpublikum ist luca muss
das ganze durch machen denn er war vor
fünf jahren bei tv total sowie das ist
wirklich nur so minecraft zeit führt
jetzt verstehe ich glaube ich warum
warum luca zu dem treffen im fernsehen
gab das war wahrscheinlich auch von
jährige hatte eigentlich ein management
leute die dahinter stehen die auch
geschäftsmäßig beraten das war
wahrscheinlich auch ein ganz schlauer
mut um sein buch damals zu bewerben der
damals von minecraft fakten buch
geschrieben was stefan raab ja auch in
der hand hält habe ja wie gesagt das
video ist jetzt über fünf jahre alt also
ich wäre heute zu tage wahrscheinlich
noch ziemlich aufgeregt wenn ich bei tv
total oder so beziehungsweise gibt sich
mehr aber interessant aber vor fünf
jahren war das noch krasser und er hat
auch ein buch geschrieben über neue
minecraft facts ja minecraft hat und
neue kommen
naja das ist auch schon die sache also
gerade bei youtube alaska und tv total
auftritt von baby wäre vielleicht eine
idee für ein video ist stefan raab sehr
sehr kritisch weist die eigenen sowie
seinen gästen ist ich war nie so ein
krasser tv total vernarrt
ihr hört schon aus der stimme raus wie
er sagt so minecraft er selbst es sogar
fröhlich ist das macht das ganze
natürlich auch nicht leicht als gast
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ich fühle ich will es so krass leute
sowas ist so heftig gab mir so was ist
nicht könnt ihr müsst dann auch noch da
oben diese treppe runter laufen wenn die
kamera auf euch das ganze publikum voll
von hunderten von leuten klatscht und
ihr wisst alle auf euch oder als ihr
gedanke ist dicker fall nicht diese
stufen runter fall einfach nicht
[Musik]
man sieht wirklich wirklich krass an der
körpersprache wie unangenehm dass gerade
war in der situation kann man kann sich
aber wie gesagt ich voll verstehen also
ganz ehrlich wie war ich in dem moment
gewesen wäre ich da eingeladen gewesen
dann ich hätte wahrscheinlich hat ja so
was ja du machst das schlamassel of cool
so hätte meine gesamte mentale energie
darauf fokussiert dass ich nicht und
entspannt aussehen und wer dann einfach
die treppe runtergefallen dann hingehen
und sich ein buch kaufen wo neue
commands vorgestellt werden es ist genau
das was ich mir geht ein seit des todes
aufgeregt er ist seit tagen seit wochen
schon das jetzt so tv total geht und ihr
seid aufgeregt weil tv total eine der
größten sendung im deutschen fernsehen
stefan raab ist eine absolute legende
und da kommt er hin denkt ist okay gut
ich hab schon mal die ab montag
geschafft ich bin nicht gefallen hier
sitzt alles gut die hose ist noch nicht
gegessen passt und der erste satz hat
stefan raab ist was ist das eigentlich
für ein buch so freundlich direkt als
wenn das du kannst auch online bestellen
also wie man es jetzt laden laufen nicht
einfach
also ich weiß ich weiß nicht ich weiß
nicht ob man das weiß bevor man zum
thema detail geht oder ob man das damals
schon wusste bevor so ein paar youtuber
zu stefan raab gegangen sind das ja
ebenso ja sagen wir sehr kritisch mit
youtube an ist aber hätte ich das
gewusst in dem moment also bevor ich da
hingehe ich bin ganz ehrlich ich weiß
nicht ob ich mich getraut hätte weil es
ist eine sache mit seiner sehr
schlagfertigen person mit sich stefan
raab eine ist zu hause zu sitzen und
darüber zu diskutieren warum das buch
jetzt gut ist haben wir das in seiner
fernsehsendung wo er sich total
wohlfühlt als quasi zu hause ist ein
wohnzimmer und ihr so euch so krass
unwohl fühlen der ja einfach kein mensch
lacht im publikum keine einzige
menschenseele ist einfach durch stefan
raab
da kommt ein junger typ bei mir ins
studio ein ganz ehrlich denkt eben erst
mal ein mit warum brauchen wir ist sein
buch nicht endlich kostenlos warum
verschenkt zu buchen
er hat sogar gerade so monatelangen
im buch gearbeitet habt ihr viel
herzblut reingesteckt alles mit
begleitet mit bearbeitet und er konnte
stefan raab und sagt ihr euch warum
[Gelächter]
der prinz ist einfach ein release ist
eine fernsehsendung wo millionen
zuschauern und es einmal so ja es war
gut ich habe ja stelle sich aus wie
andere jeden tag vor dem computer sitzt
du machst offensichtlich auch sport
manchmal ja mit den fingern an der
tastatur der ja es ist es ist wissen sie
was ich müsste luca hierüber war ein
video machen müsse sich seine eigenen tv
total auftritt anschauen und so trainer
tuchels compilation machen weil also wie
gesagt ich glaube überhaupt nicht ich
denke immer jeder bei in der position
nervös und aufgeregt aber man muss schon
sagen das ist schon ein bisschen komisch
wir haben das hier war angeschossen ja
genau
wir haben jetzt hier raus ich dir kein
controller man macht einfach über die
tastatur und mit der maus genau wir sind
jetzt hier gerade im menü ein joystick
minecraft zu spielen das ist da ist aber
irgendwas an der vorbereitung schief
gelaufen oder also weil ich meine ich
habe auch selbst für minecraft youtube
hat lange jahre minecraft gemacht und
ich habe
minecraft selbstverständlich immer mit
joystick gespielt das ist die beste art
und weise minecraft wir spielen alle von
euch dies auch schon mal gespielt an
wissens der joystick dann spielen wir
auch hard boiled können wir neue welt
quasi erstellen und die wird jetzt ganz
groß geladen es dauert immer so drei
stunden
der titel ist auch so geil gamer und
herzensbrecher ja leute mit findet
kramer seien damals war das alles so
richtig kann ich erinnere mich daran
dass extrem viele leute hat auch
geheiratet haben also die kannten ihn
vorher nicht haben denn nur da gesehen
und der einstieg von stefan raab in
die person luca wenn die freunde ich
kannte das ja auch schon ein bisschen
kritischen mit dem buch an was auch
immer da gab es auch extrem viel hält
ich werde mich ja gar kein kommentar
unter da jetzt sind wir drin und wir
können ja zum beispiel solche das
beibringen oder nein
ok also wir können uns jetzt hier mit
den wer ist das
ja oh mein gott ich weiß echt nicht was
also die vorgeschichte war aber die
wirklich auf mich macht das eher den
eindruck meine größten jetzt geht es für
stefan raab außerdem hatte ich den
eindruck da sind so zwei personen auf
dem chip können sich halt überhaupt
nicht leiden also bei stefan raab inhalt
die ganze zeit ist immer noch so ein
professionellen die bauweise ist in so
einer show und so aber ich weiß nicht
mal ein richtig gerne mal selbst den
kommentaren zu schreiben aber ich glaube
ich glaube stefan raab ist youtube
gegenüber oder wie auch immer schon sehr
kritisch eingestellt also das bist du
alles klar
ja da bin ich kann jetzt hier rumlaufen
irgendwie und das jetzt meinen kopf von
innen gerade mein gott diese dies ist
die ganze zeit das ist mein kopf hin so
versucht einfach so ein job zu machen
weil halt gerade die kamera wie bei
jeder stefan raabs okay okay du bist
also meiner sendung einen job machen
dafür gibt es direkt wieder den nächsten
spruch von also ich glaub ich mir echt
froh dass ich diese optionen damals
nicht auf dem tisch hat aber
wahrscheinlich hat ja klar schaffst du
gehst da hin und dann ja das wäre
genauso ausgabe schreibt von einer
nation die kommentare und wenn ihr alt
aus der minecraft zeit noch hier soll
dann schreibt man das auch gerne mal
unten rein ich bin raus gibt hier
einfach macht's gut und bleibt gamer und
herzensbrecher